I'm getting close to finishing a 90-day supply of 30 milligram ibermectin once a day.
Also taking bio-available Ben Ben 220 milligrams four days on three days off
for the past two months. I just recently raised it to 330 milligrams four days on three days off.
I've been through a rollercoaster of pains in my spine, of which I'm a bit
hudged over and cannot stand for very long. Although I can walk, I am able to sleep flat on my back.
Also, I'm standing on the word of God that by his stripes I was healed. You think I should continue
with ibermectin, or could I just take the Ben Ben now and keep increasing it monthly?
If I do the ibermectin would be better to take the 12 milligrams three times a day
instead of the 30 milligrams once a day. So the way you want to judge whether you're going to continue
a application of care is based upon subjective and objective finding. So the person that's asking
this, I think I remember, is a person that has metastasis through their spine. That's why they're
mentioning their spine. The way I would decide whether I want to continue ibermectin, first of
me, I don't think that 30 milligrams ibermectin is quite a high enough dose. So remember, the dose
of ibermectin for cancer is supposed to be one half milligram per day per kilogram weight. So
if I weigh 70 kilograms, then that would be the starting dose of ibermectin.
The starting dose of ibermectin would be 35 milligrams per day. And then if the cancer is
continuing to spread, or it's not improving via objective tests, meaning I did another CT scan x-ray,
MRI to prove that it's improving, or you're looking at objective tests, or you're looking at lab work,
you're comparing it to subjective and objective data that I'm improving. If I was improving and I
was doing much better than I would say, yeah, well, you could definitely pulse off the ibermectin.
That's certainly reasonable. If I wasn't, then you actually go up to one milligram per kilogram weight.
So you have to calculate your weight, pounds, looking up on the computer, pounds, two kilogram
conversion chart. So let's say, again, for example, let's say I weighed 70 kilograms. If I was
going to take one half milligram per kilogram weight, that would be the starting dose of ibermectin
for cancer. I would be starting at 35 milligrams. And if I wasn't improving, I'd go up to one kilogram
per kilogram weight. So I'd go up to 70 milligrams. You know, you're not even really, I don't know exactly
what your weight is, but you may not be at even one starting dose of ibermectin. As far as the
continuing on the fed men dropping off the ibermectin, I understand that some people want to do that
because it may be more difficult to obtain ibermectin than it is fed men. However, at least in our
experience, fed men has been more of a culprit to cause liver and kidney issues. So my rule of thumb
is that if you're going to be on fed men at ibermectin, you really need to be doing a comprehensive
metabolic profile on a regular basis because you want to be looking at your kidney markers and your
liver markers. We don't want you to end up having kidney failure or liver failure while trying to kill
cancer. So you have to be looking at that too. Now, if you did that and you're, you're
created in your BUNR with a normal range and doing normal functional range in your ST, ALT
and Elk and Phosphatase is all within normal range. And I'd say you're fine in continuing to
increase fed men is all. But again, you don't choose to increase fed men is all based about anything,
but objective and subjective data meeting that I'm, you know, I'm not improving. So I'm going to
increase the dosage or I am improving and I'm doing really well. So I'm going to decrease the dosage.
So I would base it upon that. So maybe we should have a discussion about this to clarify.